you kept bringing up
sort of coding stuff up i just i wanted
to ask uh
two things first of all like what what
programming
uh language do you like and also
what um because you're as a
computational quantum astrochemist no
yes no
that's correct that's right uh
you're kind of um you could say you're
you're actually understanding some
exceptionally complicated things
with one of the things you're using is
the tools of
computation of programming is there a
device you can give to people
because i i know quite a few that have
not practiced that tool
and have fallen in love with a
particular science or whatever it's
biology and chemistry and physics and so
on
and if they were interested in learning
to program
and learning to use computation as a
tool in their
particular science is there advice you
can give on programming and also just
maybe
a comment on your own journey and the
use of
programming in your own life well i'm a
terrible programmer
a lot of scientists their programming is
bad because we never learned formal
programming
we learned science physics chemistry and
then
we were told oh you can you have to get
these equations modeled
and run through a simulation and you're
like okay so i'm going to learn how to
code to do this
and you learn just as much as you need
to run these simulations and no more
so they're rarely optimized and they're
really clunky six months later you can't
read your own code
my variable names are extremely
embarrassing i still have
error error messages for different
compilation errors i say things like
at least your dad loves you clara you
know
it doesn't help me at all it's like
humor yeah just like you suck at coding
buddy there's other things in your life
so i'm a bad programmer and so you know
if that will give hope to anyone else
who's a bad programmer i can still do
pretty impressive science yes but i
learned i think i started learning
matlab and java
when i was in college it did me no good
at all like
it has not been particularly useful i
learned some fortran
that was very useful even though it's
really not a fun language because so
much of legacy code
is in fortran and so if you want to use
other people's code who have now retired
fortran will
be nice and then i used idl to visualize
so that
simulation and body simulation those all
fortran and idl
but thankfully since i've left college
i've just learned python like a
normal person and that has been much
nicer so most of my code now
is in python i should also make a few
quick comments as well so one is uh
you say you're uh sort of bad at
programming i've um
work with a lot of excellent scientists
that are quote unquote bad at
programming
they're not it gets the job done in fact
there's a
there's a downside to sort of
especially getting a software
engineering education if i were to give
advice
especially if you're doing a computer
science degree and you're doing software
engineering
is not to get lost in the
in the like optimization of the correct
there's an obsession you can see it in
like stack overflow
of the correct way to do things and
i think you can too easily get lost
in uh constantly trying to optimize and
do things the correct way when you
actually never get done
the same thing happens you have like uh
communities of people obsessed with
productivity and they
keep researching productivity hacks and
then they spend like 90 percent
plus of their time figuring out how to
do things productively and then never
actually do anything
so there's a certain sense if you focus
on the task that needs to be done
that's what programming is for so not
over optimizing not
not focus not thinking about variable
names
uh in this in the following sense
sometimes you think okay i'm going to
write code that's going to last for
decades in reality your code
if it's well written or poorly written
will be very likely obsolete very
quickly
and the point is to get the job done uh
really well so there's a trade-off there
that you
you have to you have to make sure to
strike i should also comment
as a public service announcement or a
request
if there's any world-class 4chan or
cobalt
programmers out there i'm looking for
them i want to talk to you
because that will not be me i'm a
terrible foreign programmer
but it's fascinating because so much of
the world in the past and still
runs in these programming languages and
there's like no experts on it so
they're all retiring yeah i i disagree
slightly
in that i think because i can get the
job done i'm a programmer
but because no one else can look at my
code and know how i got my job done
i'm a bad programmer that's how i'm
defining it
including yourself including myself six
months later i'm working with a new
student right now and
she sent me some messages on slack being
like what is this
um what is this file that you've got um
with some um functions that run and i
was like
i i this was from 2018 it wasn't that
long ago and
i can no longer remember what that code
does i'm going to spend now two days
reading through my own code and trying
to improve it
and i i do think that's frustrating and
so i think my advice to
any young people who want to get into
astronomy
or astrobiology or quantum chemistry is
that
i certainly find it much easier to teach
the science concepts to a programmer
than the programming to a scientist and
so i would much
much faster hire someone who knows
programming but barely knows
where space is than teach programming to
an astronomer
oh that's fascinating yeah okay this is
true i mean yeah there's some basics
i'm uh i'm focusing too much on the
silver lining because i've
the people that write like matlab code
yeah single variable
uh single letter variable names so those
kinds of things
it is accessibility right it's i want
myself
my code to be open source but and it is
it's on github anyone can download it
but
is it really open source if it's written
so cryptically
so poorly that no one can really use it
to its full functionality
have i really published my work
and that weighs on on me i feel guilty
for my own
inadequacies as a programmer
you can only do so much it's i've
already learned quantum chemistry and
astrophysics
so you know uh yeah
i mean there is there's uh there's all
kinds of ways to contribute to the world
one of them is publication
but uh publishing code is a fascinating
way to contribute to the world even if
it's very small
very basic element uh great code
i guess i was also kind of criticizing
the software
engineering process versus like which is
a good thing to do
is code that's readable almost like
without documentation
it's readable it's understandable the
variable names the structure all those
kinds of things
and that's the dream that's the dream
you